Let's explore another example
of a binomial distribution.
Let's say I'm playing
basketball and I know I'm going
to take 10 shots in the game.
So I'm going to take 10 shots.
Let's say that n
is equal to 10.
That's the number
of shots I take.
Let's just say that every shot
I take they're independent
events and that, in general,
I have a 30% chance of
making any given basket.
We're not going to get too
detailed of where I take
the basket from or are
they three pointers?
Or are they lay out?
Whatever.
Every time I take a shot I have
a 30% chance of making it.
So let's say the probability
of success is equal to 30%.
Probability is equal to 30%.
I just made that definition.
Let's define a random variable,
X, like we always do.
X is equal to number
of shots I make.
Number of shots/baskets I make.
And this one's a little bit
more interesting than the
flipping a coin example because
in the flipping a coin example,
heads or tails both had an
equal probability of happening.
In this situation, making
a shot is less likely
than not making a shot.
The not making a
shot-- let's say not.
Not making a shot, that
is equal to 1 minus the
probability of making a shot,
which is equal to 70%.
So there's a slight twist on
what we did before, but in some
ways this might be a more
interesting example to
your everyday life.
And let's see what the
distribution looks like.
And also, I'm taking more
shots now than I did before.
So it'll probably take a little
bit more time-- actually,
this is too much.
I don't want to waste
too much time.
Let's say I take 6 shots.
And the random variable, X, is
the number of shots I make.
So let's think about how we
figure out this probability.
What is the probability
that X is equal to 0?
So I make no shots at all.
So I take 6 shots and
every shot I take I miss.
So in order for that to happen
this event has to happen
six times in a row.
So something with a 70%
probability has to happen six
times in a row, the probability
of this is 0.7-- it's 705--
times 0.7 times 0.7 times
0.7-- I'm getting confused.
It's 0.7 times 0.7 times 0.7
times 0.7 times 0.7 times 0.7.
Each of these are missing the
first shot, second shot, third
shot, and so forth and so on.
And this is equal to 0.7
to the sixth power.
Whatever that might be.
All right, and there's
only one way to do it.
I literally have to miss
every shot in order for
X to be equal to 0.
What's the probability that
I make exactly 1 shot?
I might make the first one and
then miss the other ones.
I might miss all of
them but the second.
them, but the third.
So let's think about, what's
the probability of each
of those circumstances?
Let's say I make it.
I'll call that a make.
Too bad make and miss
both start with m.
Let's see, I'll call it
point-- point and miss.
So it could be like a
point and then 5 misses.
it?
Could be a miss, a miss, a
miss, a point, a miss, a miss.
Now you can imagine, there's
5 of these scenarios.
There's actually 6
of these scenarios.
The shot that I make would be
in 1 of these 6-- I don't want
to use the word bucket because
we're already using a
basketball analogy.
But it can be in 1
of these 6 spots.
In one of the six
shots that I take.
So there's 6 of
these scenarios.
What's the probability
of each of these?
This is a 30% chance
of happening.
And then each of these are
70% chance of happening.
So it'd be 0.3 times 0.7
times 0.7 times 0.7
times 0.7 times 0.7.
This is 0.7 to the fifth.
Times 0.7 to the fifth.
That's the odds of
this happening.
What are the odds of
this one happening?
Well, let's see.
You have 0.7 times 0.7
times 0.7 times 0.3
times 0.7 times 0.7.
But if you think about it,
you're still taking 0.7
times itself five times.
0.7, 0.7, 0.7, 0.7, 0.7.
You're taking 0.7 to the fifth
power and you have to multiply
by 0.3 once as well.
So no matter where you make the
shot, the chances of any of
these permutations
independently are 0.3 times
0.7 to the fifth--
whatever that is.
And then how many ways
are there to do this?
Well, we just figured out.
There are 6 ways to do this.
You might make only
the first shot.
You might make only the second
shot, only the third shot,
and so forth and so on.
So the probability that X is
equal to 1-- the probability
that our random variable is
equal to 1 is equal to 6 times
0.3 times 0.7 to the fifth.
And just so that we make it
clear and connect it all to the
binomial distribution, if we
were to have done the n
choose 0 here, what's the
binomial coefficient?
So in our example n is 6,
so what's 6 choose 0?
That's 6 factorial over
0 factorial, times 6
minus 0 factorial.
6 minus 0 is just 6.
So 6 factorial divided by 6
factorial, those cancel out.
You're left with 1.
But what's 0 factorial?
And this is one of those
bizarre definitional things in
mathematics, and I'll leave
you to think about it.
And I've addressed this
is previous videos.
But 0 factorial is actually--
so that it works out properly
is defined to be equal to 1.
And I did that to just show
you that this is the binomial
coefficient on this term.
So we just multiply it by 1.
That's why I never
even brought it up.
The probability of this
happening is 0.7 to the sixth.
And then you multiply it times
the binomial coefficient.
But there's only one way that
this can happen and that's
why this turned out to be 1.
I didn't want to confuse you so
I didn't bring all that up.
But we did still use the
binomial coefficient.
Let's think about
it in this one.
In this situation we're taking
6 shots, and we're choosing
only 1 of them to be made.
What's 6 choose 1?
That's 6 factorial over
1 factorial, divided by
6 minus 1 factorial.
That's 6 factorial divided
by-- well, 1 factorial
can be ignored.
That's just one.
Divided by 5 factorial.
Well, what's that?
That's 6 times 5 times 4
times 3 times 1 divided by
5 times 4 times 3 times 1.
So everything else cancels
out except for just
four of the 6's.
And so that's where
we got our 6 from.
We got it by reasoning,
which actually I think is
a better way to get it.
But I just wanted to show you
that we're still using the
binomial coefficients.
This is 6 choose 1.
And then we multiply that times
the probability of any of
these permutations happening.
And we figure that out
by we make 1 shot and
we miss the rest.
Let's keep going.
I think you'll get the hang
on this sooner than later.
What's the probability that
you make exactly two shots?
So what's the probability for
any given-- let's say I miss,
miss, miss, miss, and
then I get 2 points.
Or two shots.
I don't want to
get too confused.
Let's say they're all worth
1 point in this version of
basketball we're playing.
So here, what's
the probability?
If 0.7 times 0.7 times 0.7
times 0.7 times 0.3 times 0.3.
So this is 0.7 to the--
1, 2, 3, fourth power--
times 0.3 squared.
That's each of these
circumstances.
But this isn't the only way
that I can make 2 shots.
essentially I can choose any
two of these shots I take to
be the ones that I make.
I'm not picking it, but
the god's of probability
will pick it.
So this isn't the
only circumstance.
The probability of just this
circumstance, where I miss
exactly the last
2 shots is this.
But if I wanted to figure out
all of the different ways that
I can make exactly 2 shots, I
would essentially say, well,
I'm taking 6 shots and I'm
choosing 2 of them to be made.
So how many does
that result in?
Let's see.
6 factorial over 2 factorial
6 minus 2 factorial.
That is equal to-- I like
to multiply it out.
That's 6 times 5 times 4 times
2 times 1 over 2 times 1.
This is 4 factorial, 6
minus 2 is 4 factorial.
4 times 3 times 2 times 1.
And actually, I forgot
to write a 4 up here.
6 times 5 times 3 times
3 times 2 times 1.
Anyway, this cancels
out with that.
The 2 and the 6 is a
3, so it becomes 15.
So there are 15 possible ways
to make exactly two shots,
especially if you don't care
about the order in which-- I'm
not saying that this point and
this point, if they were
to happen the other way
around, it doesn't matter.
It's kind of the
same circumstance.
I made the last two shots.
It doesn't say I made the
second to last shot in one
way and I made the last
shot in the other way.
We're not differentiating
between, we're just saying
that we made them.
So that's why there's 15
different ways to make
2 shots out of 6.
And the probability of each
of those is 0.7 to the
fourth times 0.3 squared.
So the probability of making
exactly 2 shots is going to be
6 choose 2 times 0.7 to the
fourth times 0.3 squared.
And we can go on.
Let's do them fast.
The probability that I make
exactly 3 shots by the same
logic-- well, what's the
probability that I make
exactly-- in any one of the
circumstance-- well, how many
ways can I make 3 shots?
Well, I'm taking 6
and I'm choosing 3.
And then the probability of
each of those ways is, in
order to make 3 shots I'm
going to miss 3 shots.
And then I'm going
to make 3 shots.
That's straightforward enough
and we could calculate
what that is.
But hopefully you know it.
Let me just do it.
So that's 6 factorial over 3
factorial times 6 minus 3
factorial times this part--
0.7 third time's 0.3 squared.
Let's keep going and this
should actually get faster once
you-- see probability that
I make exactly 4 shots.
Well, I'm taking 6 and I'm
going to make 4 of them.
So I have to choose 4 out of 6.
So if I'm making 4 shots
I missing 2 shots, so
there's going to be
2 shots that I miss.
0.7 times 0.7.
That's the probability
of a miss-- 0.7.
And then I making 4 of them.
So 0.3-- there's a 30% chance
of making each of them.
So to make 4 it's
0.3 to the fourth.
So in any one of these ways
where I make 4 shots, this
is their probability.
And there are this many
ways of doing it.
And that's equal to 6 factorial
over 4 factorial times
6 minus 4 factorial.
And then times 0.7 squared
times 0.3 to the fourth.
And if you think,
this is 2 factorial.
We figured out what
that was up here.
6 choose 2 was the same thing.
It was 6 factorial over
2 factorial divided
by 4 factorial.
It's the same thing as
this, we just switched
the 4's and the 2's.
So this would also
be equal to 15.
Anyway, I'll probably do
that in the next video,
but let's just calculate
these really fast.
The probability that
X is equal to 5?
I make 5 shots.
That's 6 choose 5 times 0.7.
So I'm only missing
1 shot, right?
So the probability of missing 1
is 0.7 and then I have to make
5, not necessarily in a
row-- 0.3 to the fifth.
But you see, any given way
that I make exactly 5 shots,
this is the probability.
And there are this many
ways, 6 choose 5 ways of
making exactly 5 shots.
I could get the first 5
shots, miss the sixth.
I could get the last 5 shots.
I could make the first,
miss the second, et
cetera and so forth.
And then finally, the
probability that
X is equal to 6?
I make all of the shots.
That's 6 choose 6.
How many ways can I pick 6
things out of 6 choices?
And there's really
only one way.
You could calculate it
by calculating that.
Once again, you'll have to know
that 0 factorial is equal to 1.
I have to make all 6 shots.
So 0.3 to the sixth.
0.3 times 0.3 times 0.3
times 0.3-- anyway, I'm
all out of time again.
In the next video we're
going to graph this.